congressional lawmakers are trying to
push a coronavirus relief package across
the finish line tonight
we thought it could come last night
they're trying again today correspondent
congressional correspondent chad pergram
tells us where things stand this evening
at this hour
from capitol hill good evening chad good
evening brett well congress will likely
work this weekend to finalize the
coveted relief package
senate majority leader mitch mcconnell
says tis the season for congress
to finish up well we in congress are no
strangers
to december funding deadlines or the
occasional
pre-christmas cliffhanger in that
respect the situation we face now
is familiar now the sides agreed to a
general 900 billion dollar aid bill days
ago but details
matter working out direct stimulus
checks is complicated one issue which
remains money for state and local
governments
republicans worry that democrats could
use disaster money as a slush fund and
re-route fema funds to states through a
back door
republicans are trying to build
guardrails to prevent that liberals
contend the bill
doesn't do enough right now
in the midst of a terrible pandemic
where the economy
is in disastrous shape
all that we are talking about now is 900
billion dollars that is an inadequate
sum of money
to do what has to be done but this
measure could set the table for another
bill
under president-elect biden next year
and with coveted relief unresolved
it's likely they'll have to approve a
band-aid spending bill to avoid a
government shutdown
again this weekend brett
we'll follow it chad thank you